This Hyperbolas is centered at three negative 2, has an a value of two and a b
value of 3. Great thinking if you got all three correct. We know the center is
at three negative two, since we have the opposite sign in the parenthesis. So
this is our h and this is our k. H will be positive 3, the opposite sign of
negative 3, and k will be negative 2, the opposite sign of positive 2. This is
our center for our hyperbola. Finding a and b are the same as just before. We
just take the square root of this to get a, and the square of this to get b.
Now we're ready to graph our hyperbola. We start by graphing an ellipse with a
center of positive 3 and negative 2. So, positive 3 on the x, negative 2 on the
y, here's our new center. We go two units in the x direction and three units in
the y direction to get the remaining points. But we're not really graphing an
ellipse, we're graphing a hyperbola. So we draw a dashed rectangle around our
ellipse and then we draw in the 2 diagonals. We know our hyperbola is going to
open to the left and to the right, since the x squared term is positive. So we
split our ellipse in half, and then we pivot the two sides outward and extend
them to the diagonals. This gives us our hyperbola.